so today we're going to talk about how
to determine nutrient deficiencies based
on looking at your nails now I've done a
webinar on this topic before which is
more of a complete video talking about
the hair the skin inside the mouth so
you can check that out I put a link down
below but in this video we're going to
focus just on your nail now your nail
gives a lot of clues on what's going on
internally relating to your nutrients
and your foods so let's kind of go
through step by step let's start with
vertical ridges okay that could be a
slow thyroid hypothyroidism
but it can also be a deficiency in
vitamin b12 okay or iron but if you're
deficient in iron you're gonna have
probably one or two ridges which are
gonna be a little bit bigger if your
nails are brittle and they break easily
usually a deficiency in folate okay this
comes from leafy greens people that have
brittle nails usually do not consume
enough vegetables also deficiency in
biotin which is related to your flora or
your good bacteria because your microbes
actually can make biotin now if you have
a history of taking antibiotics or you
have some digestive issue you may be
deficient in biotin just from that and
also fungus on the nail which is kind of
a yellowish discoloration on your nail
that's a fungus that's due to low biotin
because there's some imbalance inside
your gut okay and that biotin is not not
working that well also taking silica
will strengthen your nails as well if
you have this little white spot which
this is green but it would be white
that's usually a zinc deficiency if the
white spot is right in the center and
the nail grows every six months we know
you probably had a birthday party six
months ago and you ate the entire cake
because we're finding carbohydrates and
sugar deplete zinc also stress will
deplete zinc as well and so well IBS
digestive issues
a lot of issues with your digestion will
create a zinc deficiency including low
stomach acid okay if you get the
horizontal white lines through here okay
that's more of a low calcium now over
here we have horizontal lines which are
thicker but they're not as white that's
usually a deficiency of vitamin b3
niacin if the nail is slightly brown or
grey that could be low b12 and a b12
deficiency can occur if you're a vegan
you're not taking me 12 because b12
comes from animal products or it could
be that you had gastric bypass which
affects the digestion and the absorption
- b12 or it could be low stomach acids
if the nail is clubbed let's say for
example it's coming up like this that
can be a problem with the liver or
kidney if you have this pattern where
most of it is excessively white you just
the top part is pink a pink strip and
that could be b12 if the nail is
completely white or blue that can be a
b1 deficiency so as you can see the
common theme is low B vitamins and low
minerals because both of those nutrients
are involved as coenzymes in proteins
and your nail is mostly protein so it's
not just a matter of consuming protein
it's a matter of taking the nutrients in
the foods to turn on certain enzymes to
make the protein grow correctly if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos